We caught up with Miranda Kerr at the Victoria's Secret event at the Mondrian Hotel...
...and found out what's inside her beach bag...
...and how to be a bombshell just like her.
And what are you wearing today?
Balenciaga.
So, what do you always have in your beach bag?
Well in my beach bag, I have a swimsuit from Victoria's Secret.
I like, you know, the little string bikini.
I also think another great shape for this season is the miraculous push up.
Have you seen that?
I have not.
It gives you like an hourglass figure.
And obviously a towel and my iPod and some sunscreen and...
...a little bit of shimmer, a bit of bronzer.
What's your summer style secret?
You know, make sure you're comfortable...
...because if you're comfortable then...
...you're gonna exude that kind of confidence.
How do you incorporate that bombshell attitude into your everyday style?
I think being a bombshell is an attitude and it's like an inner confidence,...
...and I think that everyone is sexy and beautiful in their own way and they can really,...
...if they believe that then they can really exude that.
So make sure to keep all of Miranda's tips in mind for summer.
I'm Allison, thanks for watching FabSugar TV.